macrón busca soluciones constructivas
los amargos resultados para su partido
juntos en las legislativas llevaron a su
primera ministra elizabeth voy a
renunciar dimisión que el presidente
rechazó para que el gobierno pueda
seguir con su misión
los principales líderes opositores
visitan este martes y miércoles el
palacio del elíseo como christian jacobs
de los republicanos a quien va a tener
que convencer para poder legislar pero
que ya rechazó la posibilidad de una
coalición
para lo que le dije el presidente es que
está fuera de discusión traicionar a
quienes confiaron en nosotros y estos no
lo hicieron para que entremos en algún
pacto o coalición nos eligieron por
nuestro propio programa
es el cántico de nubes la coalición de
izquierda segunda fuerza parlamentaria
en francia los representantes llegaron
este martes a la asamblea nacional
francesa posaron en conjunto liderados
por jean luc mélenchon que rechazó los
encuentros con macrón en el elíseo
empezaron a marcar línea política
el gobierno esperaba recibir un mandato
y pues recibió un mandato es un gobierno
minoritario lo que es un elemento
increíble históricamente jamás un
presidente de la república que acaba de
ser elegido recibe un resultado tan
débil en los legislativos siguientes
entre los nuevos diputados del nubes hay
grandes novedades que empiezan a darse a
conocer ante la sociedad francesa
de sirvienta a diputada todo es posible
la gente no debería pensar que una
señora de la limpieza o un asistente de
hotel no pueden convertirse en diputadas
todo es posible cualquiera puede
convertirse en parlamentario
el camino legislativo para macrón no
será simple y los diálogos se verán
interrumpidos por sus compromisos
internacionales como las cumbres de la
unión europea el g7 y la otan